it's week eight of the masked singer and
guys we're taping pretty darn close to
the end tonight another celeb in
disguise fluttered off into the night
sky
hi I'm Deidre Behar and I'm Charley
O'Keeffe like producer Bryan Strickland
told us last time there'd be some
unexpected eliminations and the
butterflys was no exception
watch this
oh my gosh our girl Michelle Williams
I'm saying her name look I am a little
embarrassed and I apologize I said last
week that I knew someone was someone
since week one I apologize for saying
that I was wrong but I do want to tap
ourselves on the shoulders for this one
we did call Michelle Williams since day
one as a huge Destiny's Child fan
growing up I know that voice and on a
more like kind of sentimental note what
an incredibly empowering moment for this
woman who had a really tough year she
called off her engagement she she sought
treatment and to turn 40 in 2019 to do
the masked singer and kind of come back
with this sort of eerie emergence into
the media I don't think there's a bigger
better way to do it and I've been saying
it since week one
it was the legs they stuck with us all
the way to the end I love it you know I
am disappointed I thought she could have
been a contender to win the entire show
I agree because that girl was built in
Demi Lovato like it was her job truly
exactly but I think she came to
accomplish something else and something
more important on this show and I think
she did it with class grace and elegance
I loved it
what do you think of that final clue
package anything in there I mean I
but Clues you guys I don't even need the
clue I thought we knew the voice sharing
the stage with giants of course she's
performed with Destiny's Child most
recently at the Super Bowl it doesn't
get more giant than that and you know
the reference to the year break when she
took time for herself which is important
what do you think I was going with the
playbill three Broadway shows she's been
on Broadway three times and the West End
which we saw there with the London clue
but one thing I couldn't quite figure
out was the hot tea we saw a hot tea
kettle it was very obviously part of the
clue package but I couldn't pin it to
anything truly I couldn't either and you
know that we we sit and we take so much
time googling and trying to figure
things out if you guys have a clue about
the 100 tea let us know in the comments
smooth like Tennessee whiskey for [ __ ]
sake enjoy these incredible locals
[Music]
[Applause]
all right what do you think I'm sticking
with Wayne Brady me too I'm Brady I feel
like we're getting to be a little bit of
a broken record here I feel like we say
a lot of the same things let's just kind
of go through the clues and and make our
case so there was a clue in the package
this week yes and and if you've ever
taken an improv comedy class you know
that is the most basic formula for doing
improv comedy you have to say yes and
and then continue the conversation there
is no one more of a master at improv
than Wayne Brady and I was doing a
little research online he's a brilliant
freestyler and I loved what he did on
The Late Late Show with James Corden
take a look fluoride
I mean imagine a skill set where someone
cut through out the most random word in
the world fluoride and then he just
makes up like a really poetic brilliant
fun rap about it
it's a talent it's a yeah he's just so
incredible the other big thing that
stood out to me was there's a lot of
mention with the Fox there's a presence
of a child we saw a low Fox in there
cleared around package this week and if
you know anything about Wayne Brady you
know he is an incredibly proud father
earlier this year I actually had the
honor of interviewing him with his
daughter who was his date at the 2019
Daytime Emmy Awards I asked her if she
thought that he was cool take a look I
think this guy's cool he's all right
what's the best lesson you've learned
from him
I don't know I mean I guess to work hard
to work hard you could be a three-time
Emmy nominee to bingo aren't they so
cute together they're adorable and I
love that he's bringing up his kid in
this clue package yeah journey on the
show yeah he's damn proud as a father
exactly what did you thinking with it I
know I've mentioned it before Broadway's
obviously something big we can clearly
see his a performer but he did say at
the end he is so glad to get the chance
to work with his friends alluding to the
judges panel who on there has he worked
with before if it is Wayne Brady he has
worked with Nicole Scherzinger in rent
at the Hollywood Bowl in 2010 oh my
Wayne played Tom Collins and Nicole Faye
Morgan Johnson
can you imagine someone that you've
worked with that you spent so many hours
rehearsing with low especially - oh yeah
well you think if she has done Broadway
I'm sorry a live theater performance
she'd be pretty familiar with his voice
what's going on there Nicole what's
happening Holly I'm listening girl come
on
Deidre you're married by I am for sure
swiping major right on the thingamajig
watch this performance of an iconic
Michael Buble Bob
thingamajig so soulful every week
soulful up there yeah who are you going
with I'm sticking with Victor Oladipo I
know again we've been saying it but
these clues really really it solidified
it this week for me we saw a letter from
Maryland well Victor was born in Silver
Springs Maryland and raised in Upper
Marlboro we saw him holding some disks
there I thought albums discs what
cookies mean well he dropped an LP in
November of 2018 called V oh it was an
eighth song album and he also followed
up from his 2017 project songs for you a
three song EP so he's definitely made a
mark in the music and this guy's a music
maker completely like juggling two
really solid like careers really
different job basketball and use it and
we actually have a quick clip from that
song take a look and I'm singing this
song okay so you mentioned discs earlier
I'm not gonna lie the inner geriatric in
me but - did he have like a ruptured ear
so then I started thinking like there
was a mention of suffered a setback and
if you're a basketball fan you know
Victor Oladipo he did suffer a knee
injury earlier this year he was out all
last season he's still currently not
playing in the NBA at the moment so it
wasn't a ruptured disc necessarily in
the back it's I think refers to his knee
injury and we started doing some some
research on things he said in the past
he had a really interesting quote he
told nba.com in October of this year I
feel like I've gotten better in a lot of
attributes not only as a man but my game
as well I've worked on things I normally
don't get to work on I'm looking forward
to showcasing those eventually I'm
taking my sweet time as slow as possible
feeling good though so I'm happy to hear
that he's doing well and he's making a
recovery and if his knee doesn't work
and he can't play basketball the guy is
more than making up for it by giving us
so much great music every week this has
to be Victor Oladipo investing and there
was one more thing I want to point out
we know it's a knee injury
Robin actually made a comment from the
judges panel saying it looked like
thingamajig was limping on stage and we
both agreed he's kind of been standing
still for all these performances he's
not doing crazy and same dance moves
like the Fox or the Rottweilers are
amending still
injury would force him to stand in one
spot there I still give him all the
credit in the world he is honest two
feet he is performing and singing and
I'm sure once he gets better maybe we'll
get a little sassy dancer Oladipo I
don't know what do you guys think let us
know there's been an eclipse over our
hearts and the only person we have to
thank is the tree let's watch her light
up the stage with an 80s classic
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie this ranks is one of
my favorite performances of the season I
was watching this at my desk at the TV
and I quite literally might hurt you and
scream in the office it's so good it's
really really good and you know I think
week after week the tree just keeps
proving this is someone with vocal chops
galore let's get into the clue package I
think in this one particularly we got
the most red herrings yes the producers
are definitely trying to throw us for a
loop but Charlie and I do not fall for
such nonsense the first thing that I'm
not buying is the what is a friend sign
that we saw in the kitchen I think
they're trying to make us think that
it's Lisa Kudrow from friends Nicole
Scherzinger actually guessed that but if
you guys know anything about Lisa Kudrow
if you're a friends fan you know that
that's not the voice we're hearing take
a listen many cats many cat what are
they feeding you
so of course they've guessed Lisa Kudrow
another name that they've guessed in the
past is Kathy Najimy now I'm a Kathy
Najimy fan I know you're a Kathy Najimy
fan if you've seen her in movies like
Sister Act you know what her voice
sounds like I mean take a listen did
those voices match up No thank you so
much I do recognize that voice as
someone else though I don't know about
you we've been saying it for a while
come on Ana Gasteyer I'm sticking with
it I recognize it from wicked in 2005
she actually originated the role of
Elphaba in Chicago she later reprised it
on Broadway again we have a quick clip
of that take a listen
[Music]
if you can sing wicked you can sing any
exactly and if that wasn't enough we saw
a red firecracker kind of dynamite clue
there in the package she actually
started in a 2006 Netflix comedy called
lady dynamite okay that all kind of
matches that a few more things from the
clue package that we noticed the $50
bill I was like is this someone who's
worked with 50 cent is there 50
significance well the president on the
$50 bill ulysses s grant guess what on a
gas tires son's name is it's delicious
its new listings and I'm on this show
previously we've we've talked about how
Ana's one of her first roles was
actually on the episode The Soup Nazi of
Seinfeld we saw more soup cans in this
clue package so I mean I think we just
went down like seven pieces of evidence
there's a lot there it's on a gas tire
it has to be so Michelle Williams came
out of her cocoon and emerged like the
goddess butterfly that she is but she is
not our masked singer champion
we've still got six contestants left the
flamingos the Fox the leopard the
Rottweiler the thingamajig and the tree
I've got my money on the Rottweiler who
are you going with I'm gonna go flamingo
but you know I worship and stay on the
leopard we all know who are you pulling
forward tell us below in the comments
and tweet us all your thoughts comments
and theories I'm at Charles E O'Keefe
and I'm at Deidre Behar we'll see you
next week
[Music]